today we're gonna discuss the fastest
character in the my hero academia
universe I'm the number two hero Hawks
we're gonna explain everything from his
quark to his philosophy his childhood
and also explain how he became the
youngest hero ever to reach the top ten
in the hero rankings but before you
begin if you clicked on this video then
you'd probably be intrigued by some of
the other stuff I've put out I do one
video a week I'm trying to reach a
hundred subscribers so I'd really
appreciate it if you would subscribe
also just a final thing this video has
no plot spoilers for the manga so if
your anime only then you are safe here
okay let's get into it shall we
when Hawkes was around six years old he
saved an entire family from a high-speed
car accident from that day forward the
people he saved vowed to financially
support hawks and his family believing
their Hawks had to become a hero now at
only 18 years old Hawk started his own
hero agency and by the second half of
that same year he was already ranked in
the top ten heroes this made him not
just the youngest hero to break into the
top ten but also the fastest person to
ever do so earning him the nickname of
the man who goes too fast
given that the hero rankings are
determined not just on how popular you
are but on how many people you save it's
safe to say that to climb the hero
rankings as quickly as Hawks did he
would have been very very active and
what really makes this crazy is the fact
that Hawks himself freely admits that
he'd rather be down in the lower ranks
so that he could be free from scrutiny
and kind of you know have less of the
pressure of being a top hero that means
that this guy isn't even trying to be
ranked highly just think about that he's
not even trying but yet he was in the
top ten before he was even 19 years old
Hawks is one of the only top heroes
explicitly stated to not have attended
UA which is pretty interesting
considering that he was a child prodigy
also unlike most young aspiring heroes
Hawks never considered himself to be a
big or my fan and actually prefers to
Stan endeavour due to the fact that
endeavor was the only one trying to
surpass all mine and if he realized in
this flashback of hawks we actually see
him wearing an endeavour jumper which is
a pretty cool Easter Egg considering
that Hawks is now the number two hero
directly behind endeavour now moving on
to his quirk despite looking like he
just has a pair of wings this is
actually one of the most versatile
quirks in the world of my hero academia
and it has a lot of layers to it his
mutation quirk is called fear swings and
to start with it grants him a pair of
giant bright red wings but beyond that
he can simultaneously manipulate each
feather using telekinesis
so using his mind he can shoot out
different feathers in various directions
to perform their own individual tasks
what's more the feathers he carries are
incredibly strong with each feather
being powerful enough to carry a single
person or even heavier objects than that
and if he shoots the feathers off they
can be reattached back onto his wings as
long as they haven't been destroyed his
feathers do vary in strength however
some of them are even strong enough to
be used as swords and we've seen Hawks
use them to literally slice enemies in
half whereas other feathers are more
flexible and more typical of what we
would see in reality additionally each
feather can feel the vibrations in the
air which enhances Hawks his own senses
allowing him to detect people and
objects around him if you look at this
panel we can see that horse can detect
even the tiniest of sounds such as the
rustling of people's clothes inside a
battle zone that's even more impressive
than like spidey sense or anything like
that
now the only drawback I could say that
fierce wings has is that if too many
feathers are detached it limits his
ability to fly obviously and he has to
wait for two whole days for the main
wings to grow back but just to be clear
he's actually very smart I would never
really exhaust all his wings unless it
was 100% necessary the reason being is
that his quirk doesn't actually enhance
his overall strength so without his
wings he's pretty useless now moving on
to his philosophy one of the reasons
that Hawks is the best new character in
my hair academia in my opinion is due to
his carefree personality he's someone
who always says what's on his mind no
matter what other people think
furthermore because he's so carefree he
wants to live in a society where heroes
basically have tons of free time because
there is virtually no crime which is
probably what most heroes one rightbut
Hawks is different because to achieve
that goal he's actually willing to go to
extreme lengths and do things that are
to be honest downright evil
despite clearly having a good heart to
achieve a villain free society in which
heroes basically don't have to work too
much Hawks has done things that I know
for a fact deku or all might word
never do ever and I say deku will all my
because during the course of this show I
think is fairly certain to say that
those two characters have most of the
heart of a hero but regardless of this
hooks is still only 22 years old so he
has a lot to learn and he is idolized by
a lot of aspiring heroes not least toka
Yami
he's actually taken Tokyo Mian for two
different internships and seems to take
a liking to him because they're both
birds but due to Hookes being so just
insanely fast toki ami could barely keep
up with him during the internship and
that my friends was hooked explained in
three or four minutes actually I think I
might have been two minutes
after I have to check back after I have
finished recording this he's going to be
making his first anime appearance in the
new my hero academia movie coming out in
December but in terms of regular seasons
I don't think we'll see him in season 4
which is why I encourage every anime
only viewer to at least have a read of
the manga if you really want to know
more about this amazing character and
finally subscribe to the channel if you
like this video I would really
appreciate it and I'm trying to reach
100 subs by the end of October and I
really think it's possible if everyone
who watched this video subscribes to my
channel as usual shout out to everyone
who retweeted my last video the Twitter
handle should be on the screen right now
and I'll see you next week peace